not working well you and i have talked
about this before but when i when i
i didn't realize how much you know i
derived my
worth from work before
this pandemic i knew that i did on some
level
um but i don't know i always kind of
felt like in the past
if i wasn't working it was my fault so i
could beat myself up and
there was and that's why i was upset
with myself this was the first time i
wasn't working and it wasn't
because i hadn't booked a job or
whatever it's because this virus is
floating around the world
everything gets shut down so i should be
very kind to myself and be like okay
well okay
you know hunker down this out and we'll
get back to work on stuff once we get
back but i didn't instead
i was still feeling worthless
and i and i was like why why can't i
just be with me
i'm not being zack on a set
if i'm not being zack with my cast and
crew and taking care of people loving
people and seeing
people there and making a thing that's
gonna go entertain people
outside of here for years to come why
can't i
feel like i'm worth anything if i'm not
doing some version of that or you know
working and
and producing and creating why can't i
because i still didn't love myself
enough i still
yeah that's that's working on valuing
myself enough to be
okay if i don't do another tv show or
another movie or another play or another
song
or whatever if i had to switch careers
right now and go do something else am i
going to be
happy with myself am i going to love
myself i'm trying
i'm trying i'm listening to this and i'm
going you know
my therapist is always sandy you know
sandy yes but sandy's always like
you you're you're worth it you're and
i'm like yeah i know i know i know i
know yeah i know i'm totally worth it
yeah i know i know i'm talented i know
but but i'm not it's not it's not
settling in it's not yeah and
it's just such a weird dynamic where
it's like i don't hate myself
i don't look in the mirror and go you're
a terrible
[ __ ] awful person but i do think i
definitely can't say i love myself i
cannot
say that honest to god gun to my head
somebody said do you love yourself i
cannot say yes
that's for sure but um and those there
are moments right you go in these phases
where it's like uh you're just such an
[ __ ] dude you're [ __ ] and then
you're like you know what that was a
really good thing you did and you didn't
do it because the cameras were rolling
or you didn't do it because
you wanted people to like you you did it
because you really have a heart and
there are
ups and downs of that sort of validation
and like validating yourself for certain
reasons
and um so i'm that that's all a
balancing act and that's part of the
whole therapy and all this
look enough about me this is about you
but see you could be my therapist well
just just to add to that a little bit
and also circle back on
what i what i was gonna then get into
when i was talking about
how i um kind of recognized that i was
driving so much of my work my worth from
my work another thing that i recognized
was um
dopamine and this is through
uh you know by the way this is also like
40 years of life and you know
knowing things now that i didn't know
before so i could put i cannot connect
dots that didn't make any sense
but dopamine is a really fascinating um
drug in our bodies and it's really
um a
a reward drug so
uh serotonin um
is a i mean by the way
i'm not even don't don't quote me on any
of this stuff
but we're just actors talking about
things
yeah but well serotonin uh seems to be
more of a
a love drug like kind of a a more steady
feel of things are okay
right a piece or uh that kind of stuff
whereas dopamine
is the excitement dopamine is the little
shot
little and and we and we get them
playing video games this is why people
become addicted to video games is why
people become addicted to certain drugs
that give them dopamine
um but it's also why people get addicted
to work
because every single time you achieve
a little goal you get a little shadow
dopamine in your body it's your body
your evolutionarily our bodies were
designed
to to help us propel forward literally
you get little shots of dopamine
throughout your day when you're playing
a video game every single time you
you know you're playing a shooter game
every time you kill a guy or you
level up or you get the new gear or you
a new map opens up like
they they design apps they design games
they design them specifically for these
reasons so that you have all these
little
dopamine checkpoints like a lunch box
same thing same thing there's a little
shot of dopamine there it's a small shot
but it's still open me go
ahead that's what i was saying you get
that little [ __ ] because you've you
you've cut you
check got that got that empire strikes
back and then it goes down
got it done yeah and it goes down and
you got to do another one you get
another shot
right of it so what i didn't realize
was i had basically stripped myself
of all of my little dopamine shots
because
i been have been grateful
uh and very blessed to have been working
as consistently as i've worked in my
career
um but that going
for the most part for the most part from
job
to job you know there are definitely
seasons of life that were
drier and it and those were also as it
turns out shocker
more depressed states uh in me um
because i didn't have enough hobbies or
other things that i was accomplishing
i was always wanting to go to work and
when i was at work i got
all the dopamine that i needed because
you show up to work
by the way getting up this is why uh the
scientists and like there's this uh
i think there's a navy seal has this
great commencement speech and he talks
about tucking in
or making your bed in the morning and
the reason why you make your bed in the
morning is because it's the first
shot of dopamine you get it's an
accomplishment you accomplish making
your bed
it's a little and they don't need to be
big accomplishments i do
need little accomplishments do you do it
make your bed
you make your bed brush your teeth take
the shower do
shave whatever you all those little
things you know we don't think they are
but they actually are little teeny
accomplishments wow
when it you go to work as an actor you
show up
hopefully you're on time accomplishment
you say hi
you got now you've got some community
there you're seeing your set pa or
your base camp or whatever cool
you um the director hugged you sure when
process is an accomplishment you're
going through you're figuring things out
you're figuring out where you're going
to stand and you're figuring out your
lines if you don't already know them and
you're working it out with the other
actors and the director and
all that and that's one and then your
takes and then you do a taking it's
great and then it's a dopamine
it goes on and then you go home you're
exhausted and you start the whole day
over
exactly